the Joe Rogan experience as someone who
doesn't make movies I always wonder like
what happened between like say Steve
McQueen's LeMans mm-hmm did you ever see
that before you remember how there's no
dialogue at all for like the longest
time and I remember I watched it
recently within the last couple years
and one of the thoughts was I don't even
know if they could do this today if
anybody would allow them to make a movie
where no one talks for a long time
they're just sort of setting the stage
of what it means to be a race car driver
and what's the atmosphere of the races
it's just the the idea that you were
saying earlier about having this short
attention span theater this this these
movies that are designed for what they
believe is a populace of people that
don't have the interest in something
that's more unique or something that
requires thought something that drags
you in and that was much more common in
the past like why was it more common in
in that era of McQueen and all those
other movies that they did like that and
what has happened and like these rare
examples like when a God does break
through with something like do the right
thing or a few other examples why
doesn't that stimulate the the appetite
for more well is it that hard to do on
one level on one level yeah it's it's
it's it's easy to recognize when they're
great but it's still not eat it's still
not easy to make them great it's still
we're talking about people who are some
of our greatest artists or directors you
know and I mean they and lots of people
they try on some level they try on some
level but they just not everybody as
Spike Lee right you know what I mean
not everybody is Francis Coppola or you
know I'd say it's like it it people
people sometimes people make and they
actually are slow you know what I mean
like you don't mean you're like yeah
it's like it's like in spinal tap when
they're like it's a it's a fine line
between stupid
and Claire you know no it's a fine line
between clever and stupid you know what
I mean it's like it's if I think people
try but I did I think I think that uh
there are some people who really do
think jaws had a big effect on movies
because it was it was like the first
true blockbuster right and I don't know
you know how to actually go I'm I'm I'm
wrong I I think that what happens more
often than not is adult people get the
jobs at the big companies that make the
decisions about what to make right and
at a certain point they sort of age out
they start to age out and they don't
actually have any idea what what the
vibe is they don't know what to make for
the coming wave of younger people and so
these little windows open up now and
then we're in that era they needed there
was they needed new people they needed
like you know George Lucas making
American Graffiti nobody thought that
movies could be a hit
nobody you know they they open up they
say we don't know what to do do
something different and a couple of new
voices like come in and they make things
that are really different you know but
the idea that that was only then like
there's a whole book right now about
1999 you know there's this book that
came out about how 1999 was one of those
years where because the studio's had
kind of lost their sense of exactly what
to do and Miramax was making a [ __ ] ton
of money on an auteur driven movies made
for low cost and the studio's all went
and set up little mini Miramax's right
and the result was that like in that
year you had like Meg you know Paul
Thomas Anderson Wes Anderson Alexander
Payne Spike Jonze David O'Russell
Fincher the Wachowskis like an
unbelievable array
of directors made really really
memorable films in that year and I think
it was because it was like another one
of those moments like we don't know what
to we don't know what to do we're just
gonna have to like close our eyes and go
you kids you kids figure it out you know
what I mean the thing about films it
seems to me it's such a collaborative
effort and when you have so many moving
pieces and so many people involved that
have an say in the decision-making
process it's got to be insanely
difficult to get something out that's
pure yes that's true that's true
I Francis Coppola said that the best
thing about making films is that they're
collaborative and the worst thing about
making films is that they're
collaborative he also said it's the last
it's the last moral totalitarian job in
the world like being a director or
something I can't remember
[Applause]